les visiteurs qui ont déambulé dans le
jardin de l'état à l'occasion du jour de
l'an tamoul ont pu découvrir mille et
une facettes de la culture indienne
après avoir passé l'arche d'entrée par
et de milliers de yemma le bar c'est un
tableau de fruits qui leur faisait face
un peu plus loin de chaque côté de
l'allée centrale plusieurs activités
étaient proposées
parmi celles-ci l'incontournable cours
de drapage de salle
maintenant le banc et on attache que
l'épaule droite
et tandis que le sud on attache sur
l'épaule gauche même à la maison en fait
on aime les dames pas préparé que l'on
soit du nord de l'inde ou du sud de
l'inde
le série se pare aussi de ses dessins au
i ni un art millénaire qui embellit la
femme indienne pour toutes les occasions
qui vient du maghreb à la base est que
les musulmans ont ramené en âne et
aujourd'hui c'est devenu un art tamouls
également donc la réunion porte bien son
nom ici finalement est donc là c'est des
tatouages temporaires qui peuvent aller
jusqu à peu près dix jours donc c'est un
moyen de s'embellir les mains et qui est
le dos donc surtout en l'occasion des
fêtes religieuses culturelles un autre
art tout aussi symbolique le tressage de
la feuille de coco son utilisation a
quelque peu disparu
mais du côté de la tour des roches on
résiste encore et toujours s'appelle csa
déjà en dialogues un peu fait la
décoration dont dans le
dans le temps et puis mon une
salvayre parce que comme je l'avais pas
un talent à béton sur la malheureuse
daiane témoins bambou paille coco café
salvayre coups d'amendements du soudan
même la zapa des visas également présent
sur ce village
les oeuvres caritatives comme cette
association qui intervient dans une
école en bas ces vins internationales
n'existent déjà avait fait 8 ans 10 ans
du 10 10 en dix ans maintenant il existe
à la réunion
donc nous c'est une association à but
humanitaire
en fait voilà nous financent un
pensionnat dans à pondichéry donc le sud
de l'inde
parce que nous ici la communauté des
attaches profondes avec le sud donnant
des apprentissages mais également du
savoir
distiller lors de plusieurs conférences
à l'intérieur du muséum d'histoire
naturelle ainsi l'arrivée d en dire la
réunion souvent soucis à la période de
l'engagisme nous fait oublier que ces
derniers sont aussi arrivés comme
esclaves
dix huit elec a choisi de parler des
esclaves indien à travers le recensement
de la fin du xviiie siècle
c'est henry à la réunion par un coup de
grande vague migratoire qu'il ya eu lieu
après 1848 mais il faut savoir que dès
le xviiie siècle dès le début du xviiie
siècle il y à des indiens qui sont
apportées à porter véritablement comme
pour travailler dans les champs de café
des escales d'india réservé aux tâches
domestiques une condition un peu plus
enviable pour l'époque du statut plus
sévère de l'esclave qui travaillaient
dans les champs des indiens qui
néanmoins ont connu une période bien
plus perverse avec l'engagisme puisque
ces hommes qui étaient censés être libre
et payés pour un travail subissent et en
fait des conditions de vie très
difficiles qui les poussait parfois fuir
la plantation
c'est dans ce contexte d'après 1848 que
le conseil général adoptent une
résolution le 18 mai 1878 portant sur la
création d'une caisse des migrations
cette case d'immigration là c'est un
sujet assez important parce que in
intervient au moment où la réunion et
quelques quelque sorte
racheté par les établissements bancaires
venus de métropole dont qui rachètent
des exploitations
sucrière les unes après les autres donc
ce qui fragilise un petit peu les colons
locaux sur place qui s'appauvrissent et
qui n'ont pas forcément les moyens
pécuniaires de produire encore du sucre
dans les mêmes conditions avantageuses
donc cette case imitation là intervient
pour compenser un petit peu les risques
financiers pris par les engage east
l'opo réunionnais qui n'arrivent plus à
joindre en quelque sorte des débuts une
journée qui s'est terminée par de la
légèreté celle de la poudre de couleur
ocre et naturel qui a examiné le ciel du
jardin de l'état
le au lit ou fête des couleurs en inde a
permis à chacun de revêtir la bande
indienne bonne année 5000 sont 17 à
toute la communauté tamoule de la
réunion